[Applaudissements]
bonjour donc je me rappelle l'elysée moi
je viens vous parler de choses qui me
semblent importantes pour moi dans la
vie parce que la vie elle passe vite
viens d'entendre un sujet sur le temps
la vie elle passe vite et du coup c'est
important des fois de remettre les
pendules à l'heure donc la première
question c'est ça qu'est ce qui est
vraiment important votre vie et c'est
une question qui est une sorte de
leitmotiv dans votre vie faut la garder
souvent vous l'a reposé souvent alors
bien sûr il ya les besoins primaires
vous connaissez peut-être la pyramide de
maslow il faut pouvoir se nourrir
pouvoir se loger se chauffer etc
et puis aussi vivre dans un sentiment de
sécurité c'est qu'ils ont été immédiates
et puis l'environnement que ce soit sur
le lieu de travail à l'école etc
mais au delà de ses besoins primaires et
de sécurité et même si parfois les fins
de mois sont un peu difficiles et qu'on
mange pas très bien pour moi ce qui me
semble le plus important c'est la
relation entre les êtres
en fait on cherche tous plus ou moins la
même chose on ne dit pas forcément de la
même manière mais en fait on cherche
tous le bonheur on cherche à être
heureux à être bien dans notre vie à
être pleinement satisfait de ce qu'on
vit à s'épanouir à avancer dans la vie
avec confiance avec ce qu'on est
peut-être à créer les choses ou à
imaginer peu importe mais on a envie
d'être bien et ça passe beaucoup par la
relation entre les gens la relation
entre les êtres et par le besoin qu'on a
tous d'être respectés de pouvoir
conserver sa dignité est aussi de
pouvoir faire ses propres choix
donc cette qualité du rien relationnel
je vais y revenir assez souvent parce
que c'est pour moi la chose la plus
importante
quand on est jeune souvent on a toujours
tout un tas d'adultes qui vient de nous
dire ce qu'il faut faire
donc à tout un tas de règles il faut
respecter des choses qu'on nous impose
alors c'est toujours pour notre bien on
peut le supposer
souvent c'est aussi parce que on est
dans des fonctionnements de collectif et
que pour que la vie en collectivité
fonctionne bien qu'elle soit facile
agréable
il faut quand même un minimum de règles
mais en fait on le sent et ça les petits
le centre
très vite ils ont besoin de comprendre
ils ont besoin d'avoir le choix
ils ont besoin d'adhérer et en
grandissant souvent cette plus en plus
fort on a besoin d'accepter une règle ou
de la refuser ou pouvoir discuter
discuter pour la comprendre discuté pour
la modifier négocier et c est ça c'est
une forme de de pouvoir d'agir sur notre
vie pour pouvoir avancer dans la vie
dans le respect de soi et ça c'est ça
qui permet l'épanouissement
je sais pas si vous imaginez une vie
entière où vous faites que obéir à des
ordres vous fait que faire ce qu'on vous
dit de faire sans jamais prendre
d'initiatives sans jamais proposer de
choses je sais pas pour moi ça serait un
an d'un an mineurs mortels je sais pas
ce que ça serait pour vous mais bon et
quand on commence à parler des choix on
je me suis interrogé mois sur notre
fonctionnement démocratique parce que en
france bon ça fait deux siècles qu'on
expérimente la démocratie mais on a une
représentation très particulière de
l'âme et de la démocratie qu'est liées
aux élections qu'on connaît les votes
que ce soit nationale ou au niveau
national au niveau local ses influences
notre main notre représentation juste
pour vous rappeler démocratie ça vient
de demos le citoyen celui qui
s'intéresse à la cité en tout cas à la
vie collective et kratos et kratos et le
pouvoir par la force
celui qui s'impose par la force pouvoir
du plus fort pas forcément par la raison
ça aurait pu être un autre mot donc on
peut s'exprimer on est en démocratie
formidable c'est bien non alors pourquoi
un tel taux d'absentéisme aux élections
plus ou moins je suis d'accord mais ça
va de mal en pis quand même il ya même
des penseurs qui qui ont dit plusieurs
fois dans l'histoire que la démocratie
n'est pas ce qui permettra d'amener les
gens au bonheur que finalement les gens
pour pour qu'il soit heureux il ya
d'autres formes que la démocratie des
dictatures et l'éclairé des oligarchies
etc qui peuvent permettre de produire du
bonheur chez les gens
bon peut-être il ya peut-être des
expériences qui fonctionne mais en même
temps je suis né ici en france et du
coup ben je suis bi aussi mes propres
représentations et je continue de penser
que la démocratie est souhaitable mais
pas forcément pour la fin en soi je sais
pas si la démocratie va nous mener au
bonheur ce que je crois par contre c'est
que ça nous permet de décider ensemble
ce qui est bien pour nous c'est une
forme d'autodétermination
et puis surtout c'est l'exercice
démocratique en lui même le fait
d'exercer son pouvoir démocratique qui
fait qu'on s'ajuste les uns les autres
et puis que finalement on a une
expérience du vivre ensemble et qu'on
peut améliorer cette expérience du vivre
ensemble
c'est l'exercice qui compte plus que la
finalité cette autodétermination on peut
la vivre à plein des shales je sais pas
si vous êtes membre d'une association
mais c'est pareil quand on est membre
d'une association à une assemblée
générale à un moment donné on vote on
prend des décisions
et puis il ya les il ya aussi un
exercice démocratique qui peut s'exercer
sur les lieux de travail et c'est quand
même important de penser ça parce que
dans la période active qui dure alors on
est plus à 42 ans un peu plus maintenant
mais qui dure en tout cas longtemps
belle la vie professionnelle c'est un
tiers de votre vie un tiers de votre vie
se passe au travail
donc si un tiers de votre vie vous
pouvez l'exercer de manière démocratique
plutôt que d'obéir à des ordres
ben c'est quand même plus sympa je vais
pas vous parler d'économie collaborative
ou circulaire c'est très à la mode
moi je vais vous parler d'économie
coopérative alors souvent on oppose la
propriété publique et la propriété
privée et on considère que la propriété
individuelle elle est privée et la
propriété collective allait public
les coopératives c'est au carrefour de
ça il s'agit de propriété collective
mais privé ça n'appartient pas à l'état
ça appartient à un collectif d'individus
on est dans la propriété collective
privé
et dans les entreprises on a souvent des
représentations d'entreprise qui
appartiennent à des actionnaires
donc là on a des actionnaires kibaki eux
leur intérêt à eux c'est de faire des
dividendes
ces deux d'avoir un retour sur
investissement donc de faire du profit
et à l'autre à l'autre bout on a des
salariés dont l'intérêt eux c'est
d'avoir des salaires corrects et des
conditions de travail confortables dans
les convertibles
les sociétés coopératives et
participatives
on a des salariés qui sont associées ou
en tout cas qui ont vocation à l'être
ça veut dire que l'entreprise elle
appartient aux assauts si c'est à dire
aux salariés les salariés sont
propriétaires du capital
le principe démocratique qui fonctionne
donc à une assemblée générale d'une
maison et chaque personne chaque associé
salariés à une loi peut y avoir
quelqu'un qui possède beaucoup de parts
de capital espèce de gros actionnaires
est quelqu'un qui vient d'arriver dans
la coopérative ça fait pas longtemps
qu'il est il a une faible lors du
capital il y en a pas un qui a une voix
plus importante que l'autre
il ya une totale égalité de personnes
dont le pouvoir de vote
donc les assemblées générales sont
majoritairement constitué de salariés
qui ont tous le même pouvoir de décision
et ça veut dire que il faut penser à la
fois à seurre
ce sont à ces conditions de travail on
peut penser à ces conditions de travail
en tant que salarié mais aussi on est
responsable de l'entreprise et
l'entreprise on a besoin qu'elle perdure
soit pérenne
donc chaque fois qu'on prend une
décision il faut penser aux deux côtés
on est responsable des conséquences à
court moyen et long terme
alors concrètement il ya des décisions
collectives à prendre sur le bien commun
qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'entreprise des
fois il ya des choses à vendre des
feuilles et des choses à acquérir des
investissements à faire on prend des
décisions sur l'organisation du travail
sur ce que l'on produit
quels nouveaux produits quels nouveaux
services on va développer comment on le
produit
et puis s'il ya des bénéfices commencent
leur est parti ça c'est la partie sympa
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas
et ces décisions ben forcément quand on
les prend on discute autour de valeurs
et on essaie de trouver des valeurs
communes
alors quand on bande de copains qui a
monté une petite coopérative ensemble
ces liens c'est facile mais 20 40 50 il
ya des coopératives avec plusieurs
centaines de salariés et ben là c'est
plus difficile
on n'a pas tous les mêmes histoires à
tous ces mêmes valeurs on n'a pas tous
les mêmes envies et lui même fait même
d'antan on peut changer changer de point
de vue change et donc moi je travaille
dans une coopérative et quand je suis
arrivé j'ai fait
une coopérative genre j'avais rencontré
le prince charmant quoi c'était je vais
pas bosser dans une entreprise où il y
aura un patron qui me dira quoi faire
non je vais être acteur de mon
entreprise c'était vraiment formidable
et puis le gérant le gérant il était lui
sert qu'on sait les salariés qui
choisissent le patron donc on peut
supposer que forcément le patron il va
faire attention aux conditions de
travail des salariés
le gérant il va faire gaffe à tout ça
sinon il sera pas réélu la prochaine
fois fais attention
alors oui oui en général enfin moi ce
que j'ai connu ces décès des gérants qui
sont les gens déjà rente qui sont qui
sont bienveillants sauf que il y à une
entreprise à gérer quand on gère une
entreprise il ya vraiment un équilibre à
trouver entre plusieurs types d'intérêt
il ya une entreprise elle existe parce
qu'il ya des clients des clients ou des
usagers ça c'est toujours très important
à penser à son intérêt à lui lui son
intérêt du client c'est toujours que il
est une prestation de meilleure qualité
possible pour un prix le plus bas
possible
l'intérêt de des salariés c'est d'avoir
de bonnes conditions de travail et un
salaire correct
j'en ai déjà parlé et l'intérêt de
l'entreprise c'est qu'elle dure c'est
qu'elles durent longtemps qu'elle soit
pérenne qu'elle fonctionne et ça quelque
part c'est l'intérêt de tout le monde
les salariés ont aussi besoin de
l'entreprise dure longtemps et
généralement les clients aussi ont
intérêt que ça dure longtemps et ce qui
vient là où ça vient frotter là où ça
vient frictionner c'est que l'intérêt
collectif c'est pas la somme des
intérêts individuels
or la société coopérative elle et elle
est composée de personnes où on vient
toujours avec une double casquette
on a notre intérêt individuel en tant
que salariés et puis on l'intérêt
collectif
il faut toujours comme ça à basculer de
l'un à l'autre ça frotte et des fois ça
frottait dur et le costume de prince
charmant il est tombé 1 j'en ai pris un
coup mais et donc je me suis me suis
demandé est-ce que ça valait vraiment le
coup
ça fait 16 ans que je suis dans cette
boîte j'étais salarié au départ je suis
devenu associé j'étais délégué du
personnel ça c'est ce qui défend des
salariés j'ai participé au conseil de
surveillance le conseil de surveillance
est celui qui vérifie que le jeu
en respectent bien les consignes données
par l'assemblée nationale semblent et
général et aujourd'hui je suis gérante
un vrai parcours de schizophrènes je
suis passé par tous les stades et bien
après seize années je suis toujours
convaincu de l'intérêt de la coopération
dans l'entreprise alors c'est parfois
difficile
des fois il ya des engueulades
des fois des fois c'est dur mais comme
je le disais au début c'est le chemin
qui compte parce qu on évolue on débat
on essaie on recommence des fois y en a
qui partent on se quitte
et puis et puis en fait tout au long on
expérimente des choses on essaye de
nouvelles choses et ça cet excitant de
voir sa propre pensée évoluer son propre
avis évolué
c'est plaisant c'est gratifiant aussi ne
pas rester comme ça tout le temps sur
ses positions
du début jusqu'à la fin non on avance en
fait l'entreprise elle est vivante comme
nous quoi et et puis on a un vécu aussi
de belles choses ont franchi des
obstacles on a des belles expériences on
est mû par des pratiques communes et ça
c'est plaisant c'est gratifiant ya une
solidarité aussi parce qu'on est une
équipe où on peut compter les uns sur
les autres et finalement ça m'a beaucoup
interrogé sur ce qu'est une démocratie
parce que au départ simplement
embêtements quand la coopérative a été
créé on a reproduit ce qu'on connaissait
des pratiques démocratiques donc on a
fait des votes
on a fait des bottes les boîtes vous
avez l'habitude en fait vous en rendez
pas compte peut-être mais quand on fait
un vote lors d'une élection fait un vote
en fait binaire on choisit oui ou non
pour les référendums ou ont choisi un
candidat à défaut d autres c 1 0 et en
fait il ya d'autre systèmes de vote on
les connaît pas bien parce qu'ils sont
pas vraiment utilisé il en existe plein
d'autres je vais vous en présenter 3
vous allez voir que selon le système de
vote choisi et l'on n'a pas le même
résultat
le vote par classement c'est juste dire
voilà il ya quatre choix qu'est ce qu'on
va manger ce midi il ya quatre choix
lequel vient en premier lequel vient en
deuxième le kenyan troisième baisse et
pas forcément celui qui a le plus de
fois le résultat premier qui gagne ça
peut être celui qui a le plus de fois
deuxième par exemple le vote par
répartition de points c'est quand on a
10 points chacun on les répartit comme
on veut là c'est pareil à des gens qui
vont mettre dix points tous leurs points
d'un côté et les autres qui vont les
fait partir parce que par ordre de
préférence
là encore on a un résultat différent le
vote de valeur c'est dire parmi les
choix qui me sont proposées
ce que je veux vraiment pas agi mais
moins deux points ce que je veux
beaucoup j'aime et plus de points et
puis le reste se répartit là encore avec
ce système là on a encore un autre
résultat
vous chercherez vous trouverez c'est
facile à trouver
c'est intéressant de voir que finalement
le le processus de décision fait que bon
on arrive à des résultats différents
donc c'est important de choisir son mode
de décision et en fait dans quand on
fonctionne sur des processus
oui ce que je voulais dire par là encore
une fois là je vous ai présenté que des
modes de vote
c'est dire qu'il ya aussi d'autres
outils qui existent pour arriver à ce
qu'on appelle des consensus où
finalement on arrive à une solution
acceptable pour tout le monde c'est
encore plus laborieux ça prend plus de
temps mais c'est aussi intéressant tout
ça pour vous dire que c'est important de
réfléchir à nos modes d'organisation
partout on est partout on vit dans notre
famille dans nos familles sur le lieu de
travail
inclure les gens avec ce qu'ils sont
quels que soient leur origine leur genre
leur orientation sexuelle s'ils sont
handicapés ou pas handicaper vraiment de
de considérer que les gens sont des
acteurs et qu'ils peuvent contribuer à
la valeur ajoutée de l'entreprise
ça c'est important je pense pas que la
société ait besoin de moutons qui
ânonnent et qui font oui oui je pense
que la société a besoin de forces vives
de gens avec des intelligences qui pro
qui font des propositions
donc je vous invite à développer votre
esprit critique parce que ça vous permet
vraiment de remettre en question vos
préjugés vos représentations à
développer votre votre capacité
d'empathie parce que ça ça permet
d'accueillir tout le monde et puis posez
vous souvent cette question à quoi ça
sert
ce que je fais ce que je produis qu'est
ce qui a du sens pour vous ça c'est un
business model canvas c'est ce qu'on
fait quand on crée une entreprise pour
savoir ce qu'on produit comment produit
a pour quelques clients etc dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire le plus
important c'est ce qui est en dessous
finalement ce que je produis à quoi ça
sert est-ce qu'il va y avoir un bénéfice
social environnemental à la société
voilà et ça ça peut permettre vraiment
de reposer l'important centre entre
entre les gens exercez votre libre
arbitre poser des questions aller
chercher des alternatives confrontez
vous aux différences aux divergences
aussi c'est comme ça que en cultivant
votre curiosité et la différence et ans
et en confrontant vos points de vue que
vous serez acteur de votre vie après
tout demain peut vous appartenir
il faut juste le prendre en main voilà
merci
[Applaudissements]